لَيْلى لَيْلي الشطورة لَيْلي
أنا أَنَا لَيْلى .. اَلْحُلْوَة الشطورة
نَادَتْنِي مَامَا .. وهي مسرورة
خُذِي مِنِّي الكَعْكَةُ يَا بُنَيَّةْ *** لِلْجَدَّةِ أَعْطِيهَا هَدِيَّةَ
وَامْشِي فِي حَذَرٍ يَا بِنْتِي *** لَا تَسْمَعِي أَبَدًا أَغْرَابَا
قَابَلَنِي اَلذِّئْبُ فِي طَرِيقِي *** وَسَأَلَنِي يَنْتَظِرُ جَوَابَا
يَا لَيْلَى إِلَى أَيْنَ الوِجْهَةْ *** يَا حُلْوَةْ يَا أَحْلَى صِغَارِي
قَلَتُ إلى بَيْتِ اَلْجَدَّةْ ***أَعْطَيْتُهُ عُنْوَانَ الدَّارِ
ذَهَبَ سَرِيعًا وسْبقَنِيَ *** قَدْ أُخْفَى اَلْجَدَّةَ عَنِّي
لَبِسَ ثِيَابَهَا كي يتَنَكَّرْ *** ثُمَّ انْتَظَرَ لِيَخْدَعَنِي
قُلْتُ لَهَا جَدَّتِي أَهْلاً *** يَا حُبِّي الأَحْلَى وَالأَجْمَلْ
لِمَا شَكْلُكِ أصبح مُتَغَيِّرْ *** لَا يَبْدُو لِي مِثْلَ الأَوَّلْ
لِمَا هَكَذَا أُذُنَاكِ طَوِيلَةْ؟
كَيْ أَسْمَعَ صَوْتَكِ يَا جَمِيلَةْ
عيْنَاكِ تَبْدُو جَاحِظَةً
لِأَرَاكِ يا ابنتي وَاضِحَةً
أَسْنَانُكَ أَكْبَرُ تَتَلَالَا
لِآَكُلَكِ يَا لَيْلَى حَالَا
النجدة ساعدوني
صَرَخَتْ مرعوبة بالِصَوْتٍ العَالِي
سمع اَلصَّيَّادُ وأتى في اَلْحَالِ
ضَرْبَ اَلْمَاكِرَ عَن رَأْسِهْ
بَعْدَهَا طَارَدَهُ بِفَأْسِهْ
شَكَرَتْهُ لَيْلَى عَنْ فِعْلِهْ *** وَتَعَلَّمَتِ الآنَ الدَّرْسَ
لَنْ أَتَحَدَّثَ لِلْغُرَبَاءِ *** وَوَصَايَا مَامَا لَن أنْسَى
لَيْلى لَيْلي الشطورة لَيْلي